Let's internet better.
Hi. I see you're on the internet.
Do you like it here?
Great. Anyway, have you ever seen a weird headline in your feed?
What about a photo that feels kind of shopped?
Or maybe you just read about a celebrity clone?
Oh, the internet is such an adventure.
Ever wish everyone could navigate this place a little better?
It's easy.
Just tell them to search before they share with Google.
Did I mention this is a Google thing?
With the right tools, we can all get to the bottom of that shady pic,...
...investigate a suspicious source and run stuff by expert fact checkers.
Doesn't that sound fun?
I'm having fun.
What do you say we make the internet better together?
All right. Bye!